je reçois le responsable de la croix
rouge sur 50 ans neline jel guislin
bonsoir bonsoir responsable donc
Croix-Rouge on va parler de cette salle
al RPI détente Alzheimer qui va ouvrir
dans les prochains jours c'est même
imminent ce sera le 19 janvier du côté
de morpa la dernière fois lorsque vous
étiez venu sur ce plateau nous parler de
cette opération donc qui accueille les
les patients Alzheimer pour soulager un
petit peu les les familles qu'elles
aient un petit peu de de temps libre
vous nous aviez parlé d'une ouverture au
mois de novembre que c passé bah c'était
une un vœux pieux que d'essayer d'ouvrir
pour novembre en fait on était presque
prêt mais il on s'est aperçu qu'il
fallait faire quand même certain nombre
de travaux dans la salle et comme la
mairie de morpa a voulu les prendre en
charge bien nous a fait par on a
évidemment par refusé ça a demandé un
peu de temps pour que ce soit fait ça
sera terminé dans la semaine ou la début
de semaine prochaine donc c'est pour ça
qu'on prévoit l'ouverture le 19
réellement sachant que on va commencer
le
12 avec les bénévoles à bien étudier
bien prendre place des des meubles et de
de l'espace et puis il faut en parler
bien sûr pour que cette structure
commence être connu l'Alte se trouvera à
morpa ce n'est pas une structure
médicalisée on l'avait déjà dit on le
rappelle tout à fait voilà vous êtes les
les patients sont accueillis par des
bénévoles que vous avez formé ce sont
des bénévoles que nous avons formé en
partie avec France Alzheimer en les
envoyant dans les les structures ou les
autres structures alter RPI qui peuvent
exister ben notamment à Versailles par
exemple et puis euh bon avec l'aide de
de de psychiatres psychologu qui peuvent
nous qui nous accompagneront d'ailleurs
systématiquement parce que on pense que
même nos bénévoles auront besoin d'aide
psychologique de temps en temps parce
que certaines situations sont un peu
dures à vivre même même si on ne voit le
malade qu'une fois de temps en temps
donc on a on a prévu aussi c'est ce ce
volant là et puis
euh dans les bénévoles que nous avons
nous avons quand même des professionnels
de notamment des ex infirmières de la
derrière qui qui nous accompagnent et
qui donc nous font bénéficier de leur
expérience supplémentaire comment va
fonctionner cette structure on pourra
venir déposer son patient son VO y a il
y a un numéro d'appel qui est le numéro
clé par lequel tout va commencer euh je
sais pas si vous l'avez c'est le 06
allez-y on av on va afficher numéro de
la 7 79 75 voilà avec lequel il y a un
pour pour le pour avoir un premier
entretien avec les les responsables de
la alpie pour déterminer le niveau de
de mobilité de de de maladie réelle de
de la personne à accueillir et puis
ensuite il y a un petit dossier que nous
devons compléter ensemble avec la
famille pour bien caler tout tout ce que
nous faisons tout ce que nous ne faisons
pas justement parce que nous ne sommes
pas une structure médicalisée et puis
ensuite les rendez-vous sont pris et en
fonction des disponibilités on a on a la
disponibilité pour prendre 4 c 5 bon on
s limité à 5 dans un premier temps
malade par semaine par samedi donc
ensuite pass c'est une question de
rendez-vous et de remplir le l'agenda je
vous laisse redonner ce numéro de
téléphone celui qui s'est affiché à
l'écran est valable aussi c'est celui de
la Croix Rouge à je vous laisse donner
le numé pr donner le numéro de portable
parce qu'il est plus facile à obtenir 06
15 87 79 75 voilà ce numéro à joindre
pour pouvoir déjà prendre contact avec
la Croix Rouge justement la Croix Rouge
ce n'est pas la première prère fois que
à travers la France la Croix-Rouge ouvre
ce genre de structure c'est une de ses
missions véritablement aujourd'hui on
pense pas forcément à la Croix-Rouge
pour cette situation là pour accueillir
ces pass c'est la Croix Rouge lutte
contre toutes les les exclusions quell
qu'ell soi or quand on sait que il y a
actuellement probablement un peu plus
d'un million de malades que d'ici 2020
il y en aura 2 millions que 80 % de ces
malades restent à domicile et sont aidés
par leurs familles et que ces familles
souffrent de devoir à assurer cette
charge qui qui est de plus en plus
pesante le fait de pouvoir soulager ces
personnes là pendant quelques heures est
une nous a semblé une démission normale
de la Croix-Rouge il y en a d'autres des
structures de ce type tenues par la
Croix-Rouge dans le département des
ivelenes dans le département ou il y en
a une autre à Versailles il y en a plus
d'une quinzaine qui sont déjà ouvertes
il y en a une vingtaine en cours
d'ouverture donc dans peu de temps ce
sera 16 ouvertes et 19 en cours
d'ouverture mais je pense qu'il y en a
d'autres qui vont vont s'ouvrir derrière
donc justement ça sera bientôt de plus
en plus fréquent en tout cas bientôt ou
ou oui ou oui d'ailleurs c'est même pas
impossible qu'on en ouvre pas une autre
dans quelques temps sur Saint Quentin
donc euh oui oui c'est un ça répond à un
besoin assez spé que justement c'est ce
que j'allais vous demander qu quel est
le bilan justement global sur ces
différentes structures qui ont déjà
ouvertes ben le après quelques semaines
ou mois de de de de mise en place en
général on a été obligé de trouver une
d'une autre demi-journée euh et on est
débordé par les les demandes donc
euh
bon sachant
que pour nous l'idée on considère que
vraiment on a réussi notre mission si si
le malade repart de chez nous souriant
et détendu c'est que vraiment on a bien
réussi ce qu'on voulait faire donc c'est
vraiment ce que l'on va chercher à faire
systématiquement c'est un peu un club de
3è âge un peu renforcé sans plus hein
c'est pas donc c'est pas très
très compliqué à mettre en place dès
l'instant où on a les structures qui
permett d'encadrer de de de superviser
et de s'assurer que les choses sont
faites comme elles doivent être faites à
partir du 12 janvier vous pouvez donc si
vous êtes intéressé prendre contact avec
la croix rouge on va réafficher les
différents contacts à l'écran à partir
du 19 janvier la structure va ouvrir on
a quelques malades alors on a prévu un
coût de 5 € pour dire de de faire payer
parce qu'on a prévu c'est plus
symbolique c'est pour dire de de faire
payer les petites fournitures les
gâteaux qu'on va fournir ou autre mais
bon si ça pose un problème à quelqu'un
de payer les 5 € on s'arrangera pour les
5 € merci donc d'être venu sur ce
plateau nous parler de cette Hal ri qui
va ouvrir cet officiel à morpa à partir
du 19 janvier nous allons faire une
pause je peux remercier remercier la
morp pour son aide et le lionce club de
morpa 50 ans Eveline qui nous a aidé
financièrement pour nos achats et tout
le matériel qu'il faut acheter le
message est pass voilà et vous avez bien
fait de le passer ce message justement
on fait une pause politique avant de
parler culture dans la suite du 78 ce
sera musique tout à l'heure